Hey youtubers, it's Charlie, so this going to
be my Agent Carter episode 5 video.
It was creepy in the best possible way. I
think there to mention the Black Widow
stuff in last week's video.
I'm always happy to see the Howling
Commandos again, it's so much fun
Remember Nick Fury was a Howling commando and Trip's father*, Trip from Agents of SHIELD.                             (*He probably meant grandfather)
Ok, so just careful for spoilers if you haven't see yet.Starting with
top five moments.
Number 5: Flashback to Black Widow
school.
If it wasn't totally clear from the way they
the cut the episode, from the edits,
the person we saw on the flashback that
killed her friend that was probably Dottie.
How awesome is it that play that Snow
White clip to teach them how to be super
waspy housewives.
Every time we see Dottie from now on it's
just gonna be that much more fun,
Dottie with her crazy eyes. The Snow White thing actually reminded me that Disney
owns Marvel so they get to use Disney IP,
or at least is
easier for them to. That's why we had the
Pinnochio song on top of the Avengers' trailer
The really interesting thing about this
Black Widow school is they
imply that it's tied to the Leviathan.
Leviathan is a Russian organization
but in the comics, the Black Widow
program is more of a KGB, so
either they're changing that from the
comics or they're gonna tie Leviathan
to the russian government somehow.
For now it seems like they're splinter group like HYDRA was with the Nazi Party.
HYDRA was born out of the Nazi Party but then Red Skull to them in like a completely
different direction.
Moving on to number 4: welcome back Howling Commandos. As much fun as it was seeing
all the Howling Commandos back,
this is really important for Peggy's
relationship with Agent Thompson.
He gets to experience her in another
peer group that actually respects her.
That's why you get to see Dum Dum Dugan giving all those funny looks
whenever Agent Thompson was being super misogynistic,
at least before Peggy saves him. If you
ever wonder what the Howling Commandos
are up to normally, they're just like a
normal military regiment.
They got the name the Howling Commandos just because they're super badass. So they
still subject to the orders in the
military, so they just go wherever they're sent.
Based on the relationship between the
military and the SSR  right now
I don't know if we're gonna see them
again before the finale because it
sounds like the military
doesn't wanna have anything to do with
this project Havok stuff.
Moving on to number 3: project Havok
explained.
so we finally found out what's going on
at the Battle of Finow.
What probably happen is Stark designed a
device for
the military is part of his R&D contract,
that became project Havok,
the military tested it, it kill the whole
bunch of people,
Stark got pissed because they wanted to
use it as a weapon
and he didn't think it should be used
that way. That's probably what the
falling out was about,
the reason he punched the General. It's
like it was never planned to be a weapon
it was designed to something else, for
some other function, and ended up causing
this huge massacre.
I'm inclined to believe doctor Ivchenko, the engineer,
that they stole the plan from Stark,
Stark didn't give in to him.
Thompson is still trying to cast some doubt on it I wondered after that
explanation
if they're gonna be like 'okay well
Stark has nothing to do with it now so
we're gonna go of his case.'
I guess is not gonna happen, I guess
Stark's not totally off the hook yet.
It's totally possible that someone close
to Stark got a hold the plans
and gave them to Leviathan. If you look
at the description for episode 6 for
next week's episode
it just says 'Peggy finds out the danger
is closer to home than she thought'
it makes it sound like the villain, like
the true villain of the series,
is going to be someone we've already met.
I know I wanna believe it's Ray Wise's
character just because he typically
plays
really big bad evil characters, but it could totally be some we don't expect.
Of all the characters that it could be, of
all the Russian characters that could be
Vanko is at the top of the list but I
don't know necessarily that it's him
I haven't seen a lot of other evidence
pointing to him yet. You guys can let me know who
you think it might be, that the enemy
that's closer to home, so to speak.
We're about halfway through the series
so we're getting ready for like the 3rd
act twist. That's usually what you see
before the final act of the series,
they reveal who the villain is. One of the
big complaints against the Agent Carter right now
is that there really is no clear villain.
I mean Leviathan
is arguably villanous organization but we
don't have a face to put that name on yet.
Moving onto number 2: Agent Sousa
figures out Who peggy is.
It was a little unclear from all the
detective work he did. It seems like he
actually did figure out who Peggy was.
He just matched up the bullets wounds in
Peggy's records in that picture he has,
but in the description for next week's
episode it says that he still trying to
figure it out.
I guess he just looking for definitive
evidence or he's going to confront Peggy
with the evidence.
It seems pretty clear based on the way
they keep throwing those two characters together
that he's going to help Peggy but not
until he confronts her about all the
Stark's stuff that she's been doing.
So they'll have it out and then he'll probably start helping her from the inside.
And yes, I I think based on the moments
that they're sharing
that he is going to be the man that she ends up marrying. It may have been in Winter Soldier
but I think Captain America
himself said that he saved Peggy's
husband during the war.
I don't remember if Sousa's revealed, if Captain America's the one that saved him.
He lost his leg but he said he was
injured and just woke up in a hospital so
someone saved them
I feel like it's going to be
Captain America, it will be like the big
surprise twist.
You guys can let me know what you think about his character but I feel like right now
there's not much going on with him, he
only exists inside this mission to find
out who Peggy is.
And my number 1 moment: Dottie gets super creepy in Peggy's room.
Don't you just wonder after she sat down at
that mirror and spoke in that creepy Peggy voice
if she was gonna try to assume Peggy's identity at some point. Maybe that's actually how
Agent Sousa is gonna help.
Maybe he'll recognize Dottie in the SSR
and take her down. They're really leaning on this
Black Widow theme with Dottie
and if you remember Winter Soldier, part
Black Widow's M.O.
was to take on other people's identity.
She had the Super face Tech where she could
literally mimic the faces of other people but
I feel like Dottie is going to do her
1940s version of that.
So here's my big question for you guys: do you think that Dottie
is going to try and masquerade as Peggy
and
who do you think it is that's connected
to Leviathan that stole those plans from Stark?
Right now my top candidate is still Ray
Wise's character.
I think it'll be a bigger twist than that
and actually I used to think it
might be Agent Thompson
but after that moment he shared with
Peggy he just got way more human.
Like he admitted to her 'yeah, I killed all
these innocent people that were waving
the white flag'.
I don't know necessarily that the Leviathan
person will beat someone from inside the SSR,
like it's gonna turn out to be Agent
Dooley, but I do think it's going to be
someone we've already met.
Just to mention some a few of the Easter Egg I saw on the episode. So
whenever Peggy is moving down the stairs
in that Leviathan base
at the Black Widow school, it actually
reminded me the scene in the Avengers 2 trailer
with Captain America infiltrating the
HYDRA base. Most the time the references
I see in Agent Carter
are references to the original Captain
America movie just because
they take place in the same time period,
but every once in a while I wonder if
they're trying to tie things
to the future Marvel films. And the friend
that Doctor Ivchenko killed,
the other Russian friend that was in that
prison with them, I feel like he was Inhuman
I feel that's what he meant when he
was talking about the way he sees the
world is different from the rest of us.
I was really hoping we'd get to see him
use his ability. So something really cool
forward to.
I feel like we're gonna get to see
Havok in a future episode, we'll get to
see the weapon go off again.
I feel like they wouldn't spend all the time
talking about it and then not show it to us.
So be sure to subscribe to get next
week's episode, I know it's been a little
while since I've done a Marvel movie
video but I just did the Daredevil trailer
if you haven't seen it yet you can
actually click here to watch it and
you can click here to catch up on Arrow and The Flash from this week. Thank you so much for watching,
so let's all high five, I'll see guys tomorrow.